kommen wir zu einer sehr wichtigen frage
nämlich zur familien aber nie ist er hat
eine frau hat zwei kinder
die frau du hast es uns gerade schon
erklärt ist eine ganz starke
persönlichkeit die sich unglaublich
einsetzt was ist denn mit der familie
gerade können sie kann sie ihre ist sie
bei ihrem ehemann was es mit den kindern
weißt du dazu irgendetwas die frau von
einer weile juliana weil er sollte mit
ihm nach deutschland kommen die
mitarbeiter nicht die auch engsten
mitarbeiter sollten erstmal in russland
bleiben und werden womöglich dann später
nach deutschland nachkommen die familie
das ist dass es schwer sich vorzustellen
was die seit jahren mitmachen
es wurden bereits mehrere anschläge auf
navalny verübt bei einem anschlag hat er
fast sein augenlicht verloren er war
mehrfach im gefängnis
immer und immer wieder wurde er von den
behörden drangsaliert und terrorisiert
wie ein dort konnte und natürlich war
das immer die große frage sie haben ihm
alle journalisten gestellt die habe ich
ihm auch 2018 beim interview gestellt
warum leben sie eigentlich nach er ist
nämlich putins bekanntester kritiker war
der einzige in den vergangenen jahren
der es geschafft hat
massendemonstrationen auf die straße zu
bringen gegen den kreml
und er hat immer auch die frage
geantwortet dass das dass er das nicht
weist hingegen davon aus dass der kreml
den richtigen zeitpunkt verpasst hat ihn
auszuschalten in aus dem spiel zu nehmen
und jetzt ist so ein bisschen mit
halbgaren methoden versucht ihn
einzuschüchtern ihn davon abzuhalten
versucht ihre waren schüsse abzugeben
man kann sich ja noch vorstellen was das
mit der familie gemacht hat in dieser
ständigen ungewissheit zu leben was mit
dem ehemann was mit dem vater passiert
dass es jederzeit soweit kommen kann
dass jemand ein anschlag auf ihn verübt
und möglicherweise sogar versucht ihn zu
ermorden und julia wallner hat sich
gestern wirklich wieder als als
kämpferin gezeigt aber man muss sagen
das war natürlich ein ganz unwürdiges
spiel was das regime gestern mit ihr
gespielt hat das hat das reicht
natürlich nicht einfach einen
oppositionellen zu vergiften sondern man
musste und man musste seine frau seine
familie seine mitarbeiter vor den augen
der weltöffentlichkeit auch erniedrigen
ich meine was ist das für ein land
meine ehefrau einen präsidenten einen
offenen bettelbrief schreiben muss damit
ihr mann in ein anderes krankenhaus
ausgeflogen werden kann
ja sie musste einen brief an den
mahnschreiben der erzfeind ihres mannes
ist und der mann der bei aller
wahrscheinlichkeit nach dahinter steckt
dass jemand vergiftet wurde
also das war wirklich ganz ganz unnötig
was das regime mit ihr gemacht hat und
man kann das gar nicht hoch genug
anerkennen wie juliane weil er das alles
mitmacht und wie viel kraft sie in den
letzten tagen bewiesen hat